there's a hierarchy of the family you
know there's leaking but there's also
planting of stories there was a war
hence Megan to suit other people's
agendas it's about hatred it's about
race it's a dirty game Prince Harry
claims the royal family planted stories
about Meghan Markle in a new trailer for
Netflix's Harry and Megan Harry
obviously has a deal with Netflix and
he's in bed with Netflix because he's
got a Tokyo series coming out well that
highly anticipated docu-series drops on
December 8th and now in this sneak peek
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex promised
to tell the truth it's really hard to
look back on it now and go what on Earth
happened
and then
everything changed no one knows the full
truth
we know the full truth the six-part
docu-series will show Harry and Megan
telling their side of their high profile
Love Story it'll also explore the
clandestine days of their early
courtship and the challenges that led to
them feeling forced to step back from
their full-time roles in the institution
that's not get the suffixes said they
wanted to leave the UK to avoid the
intrusion of the British media pain and
suffering of women marrying into this
institution was really frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself Harry still blames the
paparazzi for hounding his mother to her
death and he is incredibly protective of
Megan and Archie in fact sources close
to Harry have told me that his greatest
fear has always been losing the person
that he loves the most because of the
unique position that he's in and thanks
to that unique position the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex signed a multi-million
dollar production deal with Netflix in
September 2020. Harry also received a
hefty check for his upcoming Memoir
Harry has taken a 35 million dollar
advance the chances of him handing that
back and saying actually I'm not going
to do this book after all I think that's
highly unlikely when you're having that
sort of an advance that's not going to
be for Harry talking about his
philanthropic work that's going to be
the inside story of being born the spare
what it entailed the book titled spare
will be released on January 10th at and
we're told the royal family is concerned
about it and I think the greatest threat
and the greatest concern certainly for
the Royals is the forthcoming
autobiography which is of course caused
a lot of consternation in Royal circles
a lot of concern amongst senior Royal
sources and and Palisades because quite
simply they don't know what to expect
[Music]